-I can only hope
that some of the journalists
who are so upset that
Michelle made fun of
Sarah Sanders'
eye shadow will set aside
a little of their outrage
for this other thing
that happened on Saturday.
Here to comment, Jenny Hagel.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Thanks, Seth.
President Trump held a rally
in Michigan this weekend,
and, at one point, he asked the
crowd the following question.
-Any Hispanics in the room?
Hispanic?
Eh, not so many. That's okay.
-I'm Hispanic and
I think I speak for all of us
when I say, "Ay dios mío."
That clip is terrifying.
Trump asked if there were any
Hispanics in the room.
Nothing good starts like that.
If you look around the room
and say, "Is Becca here?",
the next thing you say
isn't going to be something
nice about Becca.
If you're Hispanic
and a person at a podium asks,
"Are there any
Hispanics in the room?",
that's your cue
to get out of that room.
That's your cue
to pull a Von Trapp.
-The Von Trapp family singers.
[ Applause ]
-Yeah. Go.
[ Cheers and applause ]
And for the record,
you don't have to ask
if there are any Hispanics
at a Trump rally.
Of course we're not there.
We'd literally rather
do anything else.
We'd rather eat food
seasoned by white people.
We'd rather talk
in a quiet voice
at a normal speed
without using our hands.
We'd rather listen to
a non-Spanish speaker
pronounce the name of the
guy who directed "The Revenant."
I dare you.
Seth, you want to try?
-Um...
no.
-I'll give you $100
right now to roll an "R."
-Ru...
-That was r-r-r-r-ridiculous.
People wasted a lot of time
this weekend getting mad
about an eye-shadow joke
and ignoring something
much more important --
that is a scary time to be a
minority in America right now.
My mom is Puerto Rican,
which means she's been
an American citizen
her entire life,
but she has started
carrying a copy of
her birth certificate
around in her wallet.
That's terrifying...
mostly for whoever pulls her
over and asks to see it,
because God help the person who
goes toe-to-toe with my mom.
Trump has a history of
talking about Hispanics
like we're something
other than American.
But Hispanic-Americans
are Americans.
We contribute to
this country every day
in real and concrete ways.
You can't take
the best we have to offer
and then cast us aside.
And by "the best
we have to offer,"
I am referring, of course,
to avocado toast.
You're welcome.
That will be $17, please.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Trump's anti-Hispanic rhetoric
is scary and real,
and it's happening
in our country right now.
You should care about it
if you're Hispanic
and you should care
about it if you're not,
because if they come for us now,
you know what they're coming for
next -- your avocado toast.
Seth?
-Give it up for Jenny,
everybody!